and finally new rules someone needs to
tell those wackadoodle militia men who
took over a federal building in the
middle of nowhere in Oregon that to be a
hero you need something to be heroic
about these guys keep promising to
occupy that building until well we're
not sure and they're not sure something
about redneck lives matter just listen
here to one of them Patriot jon
ritzheimer explaining to his kids in a
video he posted from his truck why he
had to leave it's gonna be one of the
tougher videos I've had to make your
daddy's sworn oath to protect and defend
the Constitution and that's why he
couldn't be with you on Christmas Wow
seems like a lot of trouble to go to
just to get out of spending time with
you why not just drink like the rest of
it okay
now of course I'm probably being too
cynical about this whole thing after all
he can't doubt the passion in that video
when he tells his kids daddy swore an
oath and that's why I can't be home
except John you can be home how get out
of your truck and go back inside and not
to be cruel but how tough can you rugged
individualists be when the first thing
you did after storming the rest up was
to post an appeal online for supplies a
shopping list really that included such
items as throw rugs shampoo foot warmers
and french vanilla coffee creamer
what no scrunchie so you could braid
each other's hair and I don't know if
you know this but if you're such ready
to die Patriots America has actual wars
available
you can go fight Isis is what you're
doing isn't saving the Republic it's
more like when you're a kid and you run
away from home by hiding in the backyard
however I must tell you that the right
wing by no means possesses a monopoly on
infantile drama queens does anybody
remember the video last fall when a Yale
college student confronted a professor
because the professor's wife had written
an email suggesting that maybe Yale
should chill out a little bit on being
the Halloween costume police well here's
that students calm reaction if that is
what you think about being a fan you
should step down
it's not about gritty intellectual be it
is not proving a home here again you
can't deny the passion she is adamant
that Untouchables must be allowed to
vote oh wait that's Gandhi right this
insufferable brat can't sleep at night
because there's no school policy against
the white girl dressing up as Pocahontas
would they agree with
which is what these days they call a
microaggression which begs the question
if it is a microaggression shouldn't it
just make you micro angry do we do we
have to go to DEFCON 1 for everything in
this country where's the perspective
anymore hey kid you want to protest
outfits that oppressed people why don't
you start with these
because saying Yale doesn't have enough
cultural sensitivity is like saying Pier
one doesn't have enough wicker it's
interesting that this Yale student and
this hammerhead in the woods think
they're political opposites but really
they're the same person
martyrs without a cause whipping
themselves up into a lather over issues
that would better be addressed with
xanax because if you don't feel coddled
enough at Yale or free enough in Oregon
there's nothing political we can do for
you it's the government's job to protect
a lot of things but your feelings ain't
one of them
you